i'm jane secker and you're listening to
episode six
of storycast 21. in 2017
a chance meeting between sky news
correspondent ashish joshi
and a 12 year old girl in one of the
world's biggest refugee camps
profoundly impacted both their lives
this is war child
[Music]
the exodus began at the end of august
but we're still
seeing thousands of rohingya fleeing
across the border from myanmar
into bangladesh my name is ashish joshi
i'm a sky news correspondent and i was
dispatched
to bangladesh in september 2017 to cover
the rohingya crisis
the rohingya are a stateless ethnic
group who predominantly follow islam
and live in rakhine state myanmar
also known as burma it's the biggest
country in mainland south east asia
with a population of 54 million we're
tying a tourniquet
i'd been to cover the initial stages of
the rohingya crisis
this happened across across india the
exodus the streaming of thousands of
people across the border
myanmar is bordered by bangladesh india
china laos
and thailand and is one of only four
countries in the world
under military rule
[Music]
since it got its independence in 1948
myanmar has been ravaged by conflict
no ethnic group has suffered more than
the rohingya
then in 2017 the military began a
campaign
of ethnic cleansing against the 1.4
million rohingya living there
using murder rape and destruction
on a massive scale this resulted in more
than
seven hundred thousand rohingya fleeing
to neighboring bangladesh
it's hard to grasp the sheer enormity
of what happened here and what is
happening
so we're going to tell you the huge
story of the rohingya
through the eyes of one young girl
a girl i've never forgotten and who i
first met
in 2017 in kutapalong refugee camp
in bangladesh
and i was born in burma in 2006.
rohingya children like zora have seen
things
no child should see she survived the
massacre at tollatoli
a village where hundreds were
slaughtered
azura said she had traveled from a small
village
called tulatoli on the border with
bangladesh
when i was with my parents and siblings
before the military came
my life was very good
[Music]
my home was very beautiful there were
trees surrounding my home
and our village was beautiful too
the houses were separate from each other
and people could go from one home to
another home
my father had lots of land and property
we had a banana tree garden
and my father used to sell bananas my
mother was a housewife
and i had a sister who used to cook food
for us
[Music]
i used to graze the cows and then i used
to play with friends
and sit with my parents we were five
siblings
two sisters and three brothers
the conflicts between the myanmar
authorities in the rohingya has been
going on
for years the
rohingya identify with
their neighbors in in bangladesh they
live within the rakhine region which is
the borderland area
between myanmar and bangladesh
and they're not accepted as bangladeshi
they're not accepted as
legitimate myanmar citizens across the
stream from this border guards gun are
thousands of rohingya refugees
willing to risk their lives to get
across
they're not allowed to vote they have no
rights
they are victimized
and targeted by the police and by
the military they're caught between a
country that wants them
out and one that doesn't want them in
in august 2017 just before this great
exodus
there was a report of an attack on a
myanmar a soldier's outpost
and this resulted in
some deaths and
the reciprocation from the myanmar
authorities
was brutal
i remember it was a wednesday when the
military came
they started shooting the people were
taken to the shore and my mother was
chopped to death
i was lying nearby the riverside after i
saw my mother chopped to death
people started jumping into the river
and i also jumped
hello i got a bullet injury near my hip
in the rear side i was floating on the
water
then i was found lying down near the
riverbank unconscious
i was carried by wycombe people but i
didn't know anything as i was
unconscious
men were shot women were raped
and then killed afterwards bodies were
thrown onto fires
pits were dug and filled with mass
graves
and the killings that took place there
almost nobody
was left alive in tulatori zora
along with her younger brother cairo
survived this mask
after i got the bullet injury i thought
i would die
i could not tolerate the pain and
burning in my injured area
why kung people carried me and gave me
food but i could not eat
i did not know where i was going all the
people carrying me
only alan knows what was happening
my understanding of zora's journey is it
would have been similar to the one
made by thousands of refugees
it would have been up mountains
through jungles across forests
and wading across
a maze crisscrossing waterways rivers
we know that the borderlands in some
places was
heavily mined by
the myanmar army
near the riverbank at the bangladesh
crossing people saw me bleeding
and said that they should help me to
cross the river first
this is a coastal area so there are
large
tidal waterways which separates
myanmar from bangladesh there were so
many people on the boat
and i did not know about bangladesh as i
never visited this country
it was a dangerous stretch of water to
navigate at the best of times
almost every day we would hear more
stories
about boats capsizing
dozens and dozens of people drowning
with every crossing
[Music]
it took three days to reach bangladesh i
was taken to hospital and treated there
and then i came to kuta prolonged camp
[Music]
when i came to the camp i saw so many
shelters and so many people
i met with my brother in the camp
and i was worried about how to manage
our food and worried about my gunshot
injuries
[Music]
refugee camp in bangladesh it's on the
border
with myanmar and it's teeming
with up to a million people now
imagine taking two small children
and having them stand outside
wembley stadium when there must be
20 30 40 50 000 people there
all pushing and brushing past you
imagine taking two
young children too traumatized children
and just putting them down in the middle
of that thoroughfare
and saying you're on your own now
now orphaned at 12 and left alone to
care for her 10 year old brother
i asked zoro what she thought would
happen
i was feeling better than a hospital now
that i was in the camp
i stayed with the people of wycombe who
carried me from myanmar to bangladesh
they protected me and my brother in the
camp you liked it
i felt safe in the early weeks because
nobody could hit me or kill me here
like myanmar after i spent the morning
with zoro i asked
my fixer to use his contacts and i said
i understand traffickers might be
targeting
the camp and he looked at me and he said
the traffickers live in the camps
they're rohingya traffickers
and they target young rohingya girls
and they will kidnap these girls and
sell them into
the bangladeshi sex trade
we're on one of the main roads leading
out of the refugee camp and this
is a police checkpoint they're here to
stop the rohingyas from leaving
but human traffickers are ruthless
people
there is a huge markets in the middle
east
in india and other countries in the
region for
young bangladeshi and nepali girls
i heard that children were being
kidnapped and i was very worried about
how i could escape
if anything like that happened in the
camp because i was also sick with my
gunshot injuries
so when he told me that these
traffickers actually lived and worked
in these refugee camps he said it would
be relatively easy to find one
and that we were to rendezvous in
cox's bizarre the coastal city which is
a few hours drive from
kutaplan camp and
he took me to a parked van
slid open the door of the van
and inside was a
man who must have been somewhere in his
late 20s early 30s
garcim is a human trafficker and belongs
to a gang of pimps
targeting women and young girls inside
could
belong and i asked him who are the girls
you
look for he said we look for young girls
orphans are good because they won't be
there are missed and more rohingya
coming to the camps they've lost
everything they're desperate
so the number of pimps in the refugee
camps has grown and it's big business
i remember him saying he said i've never
had it so good these are easy pickings
this is
the easiest we've ever had it now you
can even find people sleeping rough on
the streets with no shelter
and they have unmarried girls with them
so my business is thriving
there are lines and lines of children
without any protection and we can just
literally walk up to these
children pick them up bundle them into
vans
and drive off and they won't be missed
it was just then it was in a split
second i thought
oh my god he's talking about children
like zoro
zura shows me where she was shot in the
thigh we had to file
for that evening's news bulletin
now orphaned at 12. and then it was
time to leave
i live quite close to heathrow airport
as soon as i land
i become a husband and a father again
and
i was looking at my children as they
walked through the school gates
i just started welling up it was all to
do with the fact
that i had a daughter and a son who
looked like zora
and her brother cairo i had met hours
after meeting her i'd met
a man who'd sat in a van and told me
he was ready to smuggle zora out of the
country
and into a brothel into a red light
district i thought
i can't let that happen i've got to do
something to help
[Music]
so i set up a crowdfunding page i just
wanted to know
that she could put her head down at
night
and not have to worry about where she
would wake up the next morning that was
it that's all i wanted
and i think i was having lunch with a
friend of mine
and then the first alert went and the
second and the third
and then i understood what was happening
my phone the notifications on my phone
it was
it just wouldn't stop and within the
space 24 hours would have 15 000 pounds
we had to pay off her outstanding
medical
bills and then it was a much longer term
approach to enhancing zura's life
[Music]
sky news helped me and mr shafil rahman
also helped me he gave me a sewing
machine
and also money for treatment and to
provide education
zora and her brother are being schooled
in what's now their home
in kutpalang camp i used a fixer in
bangladesh to help me
so she has her own sewing machine she's
taking
classes she's learning how to sew and
that makes her
self-sufficient zora is only 14 or 15
now so she's still only a child but
she's
thinking and acting like a young woman
she's looking ahead
to her life i see my future with sewing
as i have this skill
i'm a tailor i can make dresses i'm also
thinking for my brother
about how i can improve his life zura is
not only looking after herself but she's
looking after her brother
the rest of her family are all dead
her guardians now her new family if you
like
are people who have been moved by her
story
[Music]
one day actually i thought about this
before one day i would actually
like to take my children back to meet
zora
and sit down in a
cafe and eat
and drink and perhaps even laugh
we cannot go out of the house in the
camp that is the only thing
but still better than myanmar and i feel
safer here in the camp
than myanmar that's what i think
despite the hardship they're about to
face these may be the fortunate ones
many rohingya have died trying to make
it this far
this body was found washed up on a beach
this year in february 2021 the military
seized power in myanmar
the situation there remains unstable
meanwhile hundreds of thousands of
rohingya refugees remain displaced war
child
was written and produced by robert
mulhern with thanks to shafoor rahman
who coordinated recordings made in
bangladesh
if you want to learn more about this
story go to sky news dot com
forward slash storycast 21.
next time we're in the uk where the
hopes and dreams of a city
fall on the shoulders of a one-time
supermarket
shelf stacker it was ideal to me
honestly just walk down
five minutes down to work and then get
my shift done and then
in all you ever dream about is playing
at wembley